hello and welcome to this NewsHour it's
just after 1500 GMT we begin in Ukraine
where Russia has once again launched
missile strikes against the capital
several explosions have been reported in
Kiev as well as other cities
in recent days Moscow has stepped up at
strikes targeting energy and water
facilities Russia's accusing Ukraine's
government of attacking its Black Sea
Fleet let's go straight to our
correspondent Harry Fawcett who joins us
live from Kiev so kiva's back in the
firing line again Harry
that's right people woke up this morning
to the sound not just a Sirens but of
large explosions uh concentrated mainly
to the north of the city that is where
there is a large Reservoir a
hydroelectric power station uh once
again uh Russia targeting energy and
civilian infrastructure we went up there
ourselves uh there were limits on
exactly what we could see what we could
report but there was no question that
energy infrastructure had been hit and
targeted the mayor of Kiev saying that
that was the reason that uh 80 of the
water supply to the city had been cut
and certainly we saw residents in that
area having to come to a park to use a
standpipe to fill up large containers to
take home with them uh one man saying
that there was nothing that they could
influence in all of this nothing that
Western Powers could influence that they
would just have to stay positive and get
through it others were talking about the
impact of the explosion saying that they
heard 10 that four of them were very
powerful and close by shaking the house
in one instance and it had knocked out
the electricity electricity Supply there
as well at one stage 350
000 households without electricity in
and around Kiev and it isn't just here
that this has been taking place there
have been strikes across the country uh
social media videos showing smoke above
at least one other hydroelectric power
station and the Russians are saying
through their defense Ministry that this
was a round of precision strikes that
all its intended targets had been struck
the ukrainians are saying that more than
50 cruise missiles were fired during the
course of this large-scale attack and
that 44 was shot down okay thank you for
that update Harry Fawcett there for us
live in Kiev